hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar acceleration of neuroscience
research discovery by incorporation of
large area of volume microscopic data
I'm Christie jewel of laborat and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by like a microsystems to learn more
visit Leica Microsystems com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send you will answer as
many of your questions that we have time
for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker dr. Ana
staff for prattle Oh lead research
scientists George Washington nano
fabrication and imaging Center and
professor of anatomy and cell biology
George Washington School of Medicine and
Health Sciences for complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
ana staffs you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Christy for the introduction I
want to also thank a Leica microsystems
for inviting me to give this
presentation today I'm going to try over
the next hour so I'm going to try to
make a case and to convince you that
neuroscience research discovery can be
accelerated by cooperation of large area
and volume microscopic data this way I'm
going to go to my first slide we live
here I want to emphasize that we
literally interesting times where the
technology impacts our lives and
cabbages in the rapid pace digital
imaging for example has become a very
integral part for existence and invited
the whole aspects of our life
Google Earth was here for for example
shown it's a really prime example of
multi layered image integration and this
tool has provided us with as consumers
to zoomable layer data which enables us
the orientation in navigation in space
so characteristic feature of such data
approach is that the pixels are linked
to a global positioning map that that's
now in most of the cases GPS another
feature is that the final image is much
larger than the single filter view of
the device generating the image data
this example for the here from our north
part of the GW george washington
university Foggy Bottom campus also
shows the layers of data such as the
important features are placed in the
image map in two dimensions this itself
is an example of player data where the
layers are precisely linked to the
global positioning map but also to each
other and but all these layers derived
from relatively independent datasets in
the scale of human lifespan the data
represents low dynamics so that we can
assume that pixels represent Google
Earth are stopping in addition to that
layers then
timing data can be also linked to this
layer such as clouds rather winds etc
all together this imaging approach
change how we live travel even what to
wear next day the reason behind the
success of this approach is that our
brains can manage relatively easy
tempering to create the zoom out which
represents the context and the zoom game
which represents the resolution so now
nowadays most of the microscopes are
capable of generating player datasets
this is an example of our yks p8 can
focal microscope that we have in our
facility and can generate layers of data
providing information about spatial
spectral characteristics for essence
lifetime three-dimensional volumes this
altogether is enabled by software known
module known a stage navigator a key
element that this kind of instrument is
that they are equipped with a scanning
stage that can fit space information
into the data set making it possible to
use damage data also as a navigation
tool another key element of this
instrument is that by capturing and
stitching together Jason images they can
generate two-dimensional and
three-dimensional datasets Beyond and
above the thing will kill the view taken
together the change from into ible allow
scientists to generate something very
similar or as Google or weird image data
versus the navigation tool while layers
that image data represents different
elements of the object and their study
moreover assuming the low dynamics of
that sample for the life of the
experiment one can also link dynamic
data into layer of static data
interestingly whereas Google Earth
change individual and social behaviors
the ability of the modern microscopes
generate similar data set is not drive
much demand for implementation
to my experience most of the limitations
are data management treatment but there
is still relatively little understanding
of the actual value of data sets that
exist single filtered view single
filtered view and more importantly to
behavior and appreciation of how to
structure complex data set
in this slide I'm trying to outline
several important to my opinion elements
in building complex my craft of
microscopic sets so first of all the low
resolution high speed data collection is
necessary to generate object positioning
map but for this this is the first layer
of data that serves as a navigation tool
the resolution is speed or university
corrected as many of you know but the
question here the fundamental question
is what is the minimum resolution
necessary to achieve reliable navigation
to the sample next acquisition of higher
spatial resolution layer aligned with
the low resolution positioning map
frequently Dax is the alignment and
other elements of the system changes
with the magnification by changing
magnification resulting in the data XY
shift which will require alignment of
the layers then building a layered data
set by choosing low and high resolution
data set high resolution data is always
more expensive to generate story
structure layer data allows for
capturing the low profile Rio state as
well resolution while the only high
profile areas that require the high
resolution but still link to the low
resolution map use of image data as a
navigation tool or with an arrow words
interaction in the scanning stage of
your position of positioning map image
this is important to receive a feedback
from a low resolution image which is
critical skill enabling the investigator
to navigate quickly within the sample
with reliability
then after we have new things that are
challenge for us like dealing with
timing and stitching artifacts and
shapes there is a whole new dimension of
the image our device running from stage
movements or as additive function of
otherwise minimal aberration and image
distortion this then everybody has to be
aware that to prevent as much as
possible then fusion of very large image
datasets a dramatically different
resolution and finally understanding
really the signal generation and respect
and post-processing downstream to the
pixel grayscale value so with this image
from our mouse brain Apple I tried to
emphasize on the importance for the
solid neuroscience research for sample
from functionally precise book of
mirrors here for example the neurons in
layer 2 3 the primary motor cortex are
functionally different than the layer 2
trainers of the Jason primary cells
recording the type of architectural map
which is on the left side to the missile
staining include cell density is what
the neuroanatomist needs as a base
information to define border of the
cortex on the other hand most of those
neurons who sent axis beyond the cell
body and then dried and much beyond the
field of view of single filtered view
which is taken and desired resolution
for let's say for example dendritic
resolution with in other words a real
data set will be include volumetric data
than our brain and all elements of the
neurons
unfortunately the brain is not to fake
and the technique that allow for imaging
the entire brain a resolution limiting
so the Simone transparency problem the
brain neuroscience research experience
the form of the so called clearing
business the common of dr-dos techniques
is that they can bring the optical
properties of the brain to predictable
and uniform transparency with known
refractive index the non refractive
index a low for selection of proper
optics in this reduction of spherical
aberrations when large volume were
captured with confocal microscope this
should clearing with benzio benzoin has
been introduced to the anatomical
research but german art mr. fountain
halts who realized that the organic
solvents can remove the lipids and those
whole organs can be cleared in structure
study so despite a number of techniques
available currently for clearing the
brains we use the recent modification
we have been refining imaging for about
five years now as we started with 10x
magnification X objective with 0.45
numerical aperture lens in this example
then there imbrue has been cleared to be
a vp even labeled with marker for neuron
specific filament qj1
the data represents the volume of the
entire embryo that is about one
millimeter thick the final volume is
produced by stitching three by three
adjacent volumes which as a final result
gives a resolution of a cranial nerve
while also provides us with the
morphology of membrane in this case the
great channel represent out fluorescence
which has been spectrally separated from
the two j14s and failing your spectral
mixing in this case also one has to
really think of what is available with
imaging technology for example 0.45
numerical aperture can provide to the
desired working distance to image a
volume of a millimeter but at the same
time will compromise the resolution
necessary to resolve the single axon
we've been further exploring options
that scale to overcome this limitation
by testing different objective lenses we
identified several multi immersion
lenses that would allow us to improve
the resolution with numerical aperture
ranging from 0.75 to 0.85 to refractive
index which perfectly matches wanted to
be a video refractive index in this
example 1/2 of 10.5 mouse embryo has
been imaged with 25 X 0.8 or immersion
lens using a spinning disc technology
the working distance is only about 500
microns from the coverslip which
requires imaging only 1/2 of the embryo
at the time however we gain the dramatic
improvement index and wire resolution
allowing us to analyze single-axle
despite that the perfect match of the
refractive index this type of data is
compromised in disease D axis since the
spinning this technology does not
perform well away from the course it
also committed illogical driving force
for us was the question of how
individual neurons and their axial is
developed in mouse model of the human
disease
our group led by Anthony La Mancha was
generously funded by program NIH program
grant to utilize mouse model of a human
development to disease clinically
manifested with DiGeorge syndrome or
also known as 22 q q 11 point 2 deletion
syndrome I will not go into a great
detail about the disease in the mouse
model because this talk is mainly
focused on the methodological aspects of
the work but would like to highlight
several important points that drive our
experimental design there is remarkable
similarity between symptoms presented in
the large deletion Mouse and the 22 q 11
deletion syndrome in humans
however our main focus for this work
with the stage which we believe involves
compromise development or maintenance at
the trainee owners so worse the human
disease is caused by spontaneous
deletion of a tree mega base pair region
in the chromosome 22 in the region
specified with two 11.2 the the most
frequent deletion includes reduced one
point 5 mega base pair region
the mouse or to log of this region is he
trading chromosome 16 as the mouse model
that we utilize is a popular as large
Dell and corresponds very well to human
typical human deletion so the work of
Baskar Pinsky using qj1 labeling from
the calabria identified the development
of the cranial nerves is compromised in
the large deletion however we wanted to
move this studies to the next level and
to investigate the contribution of
single motor or sensory neurons there
are axonal trajectories with the
branchial arches and the central process
is entering the neural tube in order to
address this kind of question we turn to
neuronal tracers if we turn into
approach that I have been previously
developed to study the distribution of
gravity sensing organs nurse using
chicken model this slide is an example
of alexa conjugated by site in
simultaneously injected in sample and
retrieval nervous a five-day sort of
chickens the injections resulted in
complete labeling of the central process
of this tangerine murals
within one hour after the application
however this slide also illustrates how
the data is presented in an era of
limited technology analyzing individual
zero sections with a hope to put an
accurate three-dimensional model of the
fiber distribution this point here
represents the high power example the
quality by citing tracers can provide in
resolving synaptic terminals and absence
in this case Skype cowpower images were
taken from vestibular nuclear receiving
culturally terminals allowing
identification of synaptic terminals and
the primary vestibular reference however
despite we kept track of the location of
these high-power images the relation to
the overall context is missing
you
obviously to interrogate that normal
plant finding in single neurons from
embryo the previous approach is not an
option
therefore we combine clearing and
tracing with the aim to generate
high-resolution volume from the region
of the embryo that includes the
peripheral target with a narrows the
mandibular branch enlarges the
trigeminal ganglion and the
corresponding regions of the neural tube
so briefly the embryos are removed from
daughterís and kept alive in medium the
tracer is inject in the branchial arch
and the visual control and the memories
are allowed to survive in the medium for
an hour before being fixed no other
visualizations that is necessary
the challenge for imaging this large
bonum is the division of the tracer
which is within the white box in this
particular image is much brighter than
the region containing federal great
label neurons within the red box for
example the conventional way of put put
on imaging using Modell California
pliers and continuous signal processing
followed by digital is Asian in
principle result result in either
saturation of the injection site or a
lot of the data were weak labeling is
present in order to surmount this
problem we use like a hybrid flim gated
peppers in photon counting regime and
excited the sample daily megahertz
picosecond pulse stores using this
approach the pixel brightness represents
the number of photon arriving at the
detect within a given period of time to
maintain the linearity of data we lower
the presence output by decreasing the
output of excitation source and we use
temporal integration to achieve put
reasonable photon counting
the overall data and outcomes after
applying this approach has been
presented previously in previous
Lockwood's webinar by our program cause
of Zara matahari and you can follow the
link to this presentation to do the
webinar however the most important is
that by proper aberration correction
matching the refractive index of da DB
with like a 20x 0.75 all immersion lens
you can produce image quality allowing
for further image processing and
analysis without compromise the dynamic
range is excellent allowing for
visualization without saturation and
injection site and the finest process of
the three terminal sensory and the motor
neurons I want you to consider that this
volume is also produced by close to
Nyquist pixel sizes in spacing as a
result of smoking each data the next
step of structuring the image data as in
this case changing the processing
segmenting the cell body is greatly
facilitated without obstructions
you
the final outcome of this study is that
the axonal growth is compromised in the
large deletion the prapannam represents
a geminal sensory neurons that have been
traced and for analysis where is the
graph illustrate the higher frequency of
branching and whooping kin the large
deletion anyone so ever in order to move
this type of studies studies to the next
level and to investigate that so long
drop in detail we need much higher
resolution approaches and well-known
limitation of the light microscopy is
the limited resolution limiting around
250 nanometers in the best-case scenario
at the same time electron microscopy
offers much higher resolution but the
trading is inconvenience tedious sample
processing and until recently very
limited filtered view we've been
developing well light microscopy
approaches that can generate the image
sets beyond single filter view as you
can see on the upper left panel here
representing a large area of a coverslip
containing two terminal sensory neurons
and very high resolution the
registration is achieved with the like a
navigator module which allows not only
to capture a large area but also to
integrate low and high resolution
imaging data and to use the low
resolution estava Gatien tool the
integration of life is file format to a
very similar software that is used in
our term fisher api electron microscopes
allows us to easily integrate and align
light microscopy in electron microscopy
data as shown on the upper right panel
we also work on different approaches so
as images on the bottom-left
for example illustrate sample that has
been imaged previously with the like a
navigator and you can see that high
power magnification in the lower right
panel increasing magnification in this
case
useful to resist printed patterns on
silicon wafer which silicon wafer has
been used for substrate to grow the
neurons on so now this movie illustrate
the resolution and the field of view
that can be routinely achieved from cell
culture experiments using quite an
allocation model the navigator module
this or explanted trigeminal ganglion
cells in this case from the large
deletion animal were labeling with
nonspecific specific film and qj1
shown in red and actin shown in brain I
would like to underline here that the
necessity of generating high-resolution
large area data is that in order to
quantify the axonal growth of
normalities one needs really to
interaction from the cell body to the
product or growth cones so ii next movie
shows the image set present from the
previous slide but the data has been
used to generate high-resolution
scanning electron microscopy image in a
similar way what has been used to
generate a light microscopy data as you
can clearly see the topology p.m. which
is achieved whatever hurt or missed I
can reactron detectors are the next two
dimension to the confidential analysis
that includes membrane morphology and
eliminates ambiguity in discriminating
cover lapping from branching axons
now I would like to move from the
trigeminal system to the hypoglossal
nucleus which is the brainstem model
nucleus containing the neurons
innervating the tongue again our
interest in this targeted because of the
feeling of normality is clinically
documented in the 22 q11 - deletion
syndrome our overarching hypothesis for
this study was that the neuronal
survival is compromised in large
division does the quality and quantity
of the top down generation top miner
develop this very nice brilliant
approach that included crossing of the
large division mouse with the community
of transfer Aisling GFP report online
does all motor neurons in the brain stem
on glowing GFP this approach the lowest
occurred hundred micron thick sections
and to capture at high resolution a
volume of the entire head Walsall
nucleus which is present at the centre
of the images the box in the lower left
corner of the images to the left
represents a single field of view
composing the final image sets the high
resolution gave us the ability to apply
threshold based and seed point
segmentation image analysis approaches
and to extract the cell volumes and to
use the cell volume as a biomarker for
neuronal degeneration after pulling
together hundreds of neurons to form
increased mobility in the cell size in
addition to reduced min volume despite
that this data part despite the fact
that this data posit significance this
data was more indicated rather than
determinative of neuronal degeneration
we further used single bite site and
injected cells as it's shown on this low
power magnification to analyze the
changes in the dendritic branching and
the morphologist biomarkers for neuronal
degeneration so here is the lower the
lower magnification map of entire brain
stem section and you can see a tree
neurons are labeled two two on the left
side one on the right side first of all
this map indicates the piece of motor
neurons second we can validate this or
happy local news by following the axon
to the interview intro made you are part
of the at local nerve which is going
from the cell body to the lateral
adventure of the section
this allows us to produce very
high-quality dissertation at micro
section so most of the dendrites are
within the section and it can give us
you know very nice picture of the normal
head work for motor neurons quite
variable from neuron to neuron but we
can do the segmentation of the dendrites
and eventually we can use pieces and
metrics for Diagnostics this is a
counterpart of how Google for motor
neuron taken from the large division
animal low magnification this is usually
the first step this is the low
magnification map indicating the neuron
and clearly actually going into a
hyperlocal nerve very important here is
to notice if you move a little bit away
of the hypoglossal nucleus you you
capture completely different quality of
neurons so this is the first thing that
we need to verify the dolphin you know
that a patch clamp here they belong to
the hypoglossal nucleus so now this
movie produced by stitching 9 confocal
borders from these 300 micron brine
flies represent the single by exciting
injected hypoglossal neurons when we
look at the high resolution the drinking
trees clear morphological changes of
neural degeneration such as this
corkscrew dendrite that can be observed
although not all dendrites show signs of
abnormality here in general to produce
such an outcome damages need to support
single dendrite dendrite resolution but
less than a micron in addition the high
resolution is necessary to support the
next step of the structure into the
image data and in this case film and
segmentation and the termination of the
dendritic branching pattern
so although we've done all the right
things the qualitative data is more
dominant than the quantitative date the
quantitative analysis complexity rule
and straightness is not rich
significance but the causal work however
as shown on the lower graphs offer some
indicators suggesting and compromise
complexity the critic trick but this is
happening at the very distal dendrites
at the same time the qualitative changes
in the more proximal dendrites cannot
drive the data two significant
differences this is the light microscopy
suggested as the possibility of neuronal
degeneration but the department
postnatal base 7 this may be just
unfolding pathology we decided to take a
different approach and to use
high-resolution electron microscopy
imaging to define that normality in the
hypoglossal nucleus neurons in the large
deletion and to test directly the
hypothesis that there is an wrong sparse
neuronal degeneration occurring in these
neurons the conventional TM so ever will
represent the sampling challenge since
we are most likely dealing with onset of
pathological process where a spike of
rare events will indicate pathology so
we need to increase the sample area in
the sample size moreover if the system
is compromised by a neuronal Network low
dependent or older generation that
normality will be more pronounced at the
later stages of the postnatal
development with the filter mission
electron sources the implementation of
solid state detectors the scanning
electron microscopy now offers new
dimensions for imaging at high
resolution this example of paper that
they influenced me a lot that utilizes
zero sections are placed on silicon for
SEM imaging adulterous modified little
de particle staining procedure to
enhance
backscattering from the sample in
principle the SEM will produce the same
quality but in the world of intensity
relative to the TM the use of a TMS
alternative of TM is developing rapidly
with new detectors and technology
emerging technology altogether aiming
for registration of large area at high
resolution this paper published in
journals microscopy for example
introduced the multi beam SEM aiming to
produce 60 plus frames simultaneously at
resolution now close to four nanometer
this altogether dramatic increases the
acquisition time and the cost of
experiment we began our group began to
concentrate their forth along this line
several years ago this paper illustrates
our first attempt to use a tool
originally designed for nano fabrication
to produce large Airy registration
fundamentally the instrument they're
designed for nanofabrication are kind of
better suited to serve imaging needs
because the precision of their scanning
stages and some stuff with sample
stability in our case we utilize that
the item official Cheerios hideous
NanoLab 660 which in principle is a dog
beam fifth SEM
scanning electromicroscope we also
rapini use a retractable detector that
is shown on the wall left corner just
under the Pope is called concentric back
scattering detector to capture the
backscatter electron from the sample
this slide here represents almost entire
cross-section of a mouse brain stem at
the level of the hypoglossal nucleus
this section is around 120 nanometer
thick and it's placed on silicon
substrate using thermo Fisher map
software we first generate low
magnification image whoyou which is
usually about 600 times magnification
and this image dominates the the picture
here this image provides some cell or
structure which is sufficient for visual
feedback to precisely identify areas of
interest and it serves also as
positioning map further layers are taken
at higher magnification and pixel sizes
about 1.6 nanometers high resolution
layers are shown in light blue squares
here as the central layer is from the
hypoglossal nucleus and the layer to the
left or from the related regions of the
spinal trigeminal nucleus this we
capture the valuable real estate for
this study it's higher resolution and
use the rest of the navigation but the
rest is a navigation tool and global
positioning map so this movie here
represents the era of the hypoglossal
nucleus from the adult while wild-type
mouse now from the high altitude you can
see the boxes that represent the single
filter view composing the final
registration each image is about 300 mm
horizontal pixels and a pixel measured
about 1.6 nanometers while we are going
to high resolution we can well we can
figure out well-defined features such as
Golgi and positive
and synapses character is because the
normal neuronal morphology the
resolution of this data set allows us to
use well-defined cell organelles as
criteria for identification of the cell
or alterations in our solution the data
set has been already partially segmented
in a release division 40 in particular
the cell bodies in the mitochondria
please you can point here the density
now we are flying cover the missile
substance this is rough and Department
ik reticulum work at the well-organized
rough endoplasmic reticulum mitochondria
with characteristic race day on the
surface of the cell we can see different
synapses making contact with the cell
body
pretty pretty normal
Golgi apparatus the cell very
characteristic nasal substance with a
lot of ribosomes and rough endoplasmic
reticulum
you
so now I'm going to move to the similar
data set that has been taken from the
large deletion counterpart of the
hypoglossal your views and the first
thing we are done is no one oneself
here and we can now we can go to the
lower altitudes and to see the the
cellar morphology here are the
intermediate magnification one can see
the initial substance is dramatically
reduced when we don't further we can see
that the golgi is altered and this is
very typical Golgi stress the
mitochondria have less priests a and the
matrix density the mathematics electron
density is much lower level but while we
continue to fly over this neuron we can
see other changes the nuclear envelope
is still round and normal the surface is
relatively normal but the amount of
ribosomes and the rough endoplasmic
reticulum is dramatically reduced here
we are going to the center of the field
to the abnormal golgi you see the
mitochondrion the synapses they're still
synapses on the surface of the cell body
now we are going to move to another
neuron but you know the hell did you you
can see pretty much the frequency of
these events so now this is a neuron
that you know in intermediate
magnification now we can see very
irregularity of the nuclear envelope
from the cell is shrunken this is
initial stages of technologies the
nucleus is undergoing technologies with
the most important now is Golgi the the
rough endoplasmic reticulum is slash
it's decides what this little comprise
be to see the right size of the surface
of the cell the synapse will diminish
but they are large white areas which
represents hypertrophic as precise most
likely there are still synapses with
different types of magical from the cell
body but this is typical initial stages
of dark degeneration of motor new
you
so a little further so the conclusion
here is this is Golgi that is kind of
undergoing Harry's trance right now the
conclusion here is you know for this
type of Diagnostics we need you know
seller resolutions of seller resolution
at the level of a single organelle the
smallest organelle at the same time we
need the context to find these
incidences where incidences of these
cells the very coming now I'm gonna move
to another cell that is in a more
advanced stage and most likely which is
irreversible stage stage of neuronal
degeneration but again you can see that
they are you know in the dark side wall
so nuclear two case that dismiss the
dull Mouse so the nucleus is truly big
notic now so most likely this is this
this is final stages of neuronal
degeneration the surface using up this
left on the surface the mitochondria are
getting out or the gouges their
strengths typical all the
characteristics here that we are
experienced that we are observing right
now on the left side another ecology
that is heavily strand but typical
characteristic and of the combination
morphological changes in the
mitochondria and other cell organelles
by cross and deposit acoustic form and
Golgi indicators this most likely this
is neurosurgery link with oxidative
stress
you
so this slide here presents some very
interesting biometric outcomes deriving
from the previous and other similar
image sets on the upper right you can
see the sample size with the
quantification of the mitochondria from
the still from the single section well
as the result is an argument where we
cut along the axis or cross the axis so
the result is a probability with this
kind of data they start both sides the
things are getting kind of more
definitive so the parole that the data
represents mitochondria density and they
have to go for multiple neurons now so
the lower raw data represents the
average share of the mitochondria of
individual mitochondria the box of as I
mentioned on the per corner represents a
substantial sample size used for this
study this altogether would be
challenging to collect under
conventional approaches like
transmission electron microscopy the
four groups that we pull together here
represents p7 postnatal than seven
wild-type and large division and adult
animal small type in large deletion as
expected with the age the mitochondria
density in the multi neurons increased
but the area of the mitochondria doesn't
change the mitochondria p7 large tell
the increasing density but decrease in
area this itself this matrix indicates
is a larger number or small a smaller
mitochondrion and indicates clearly
compromised might of Genesis however in
adult we observed a highly significant
decrease in the mitochondria density
that is complemented by increasing the
surface area of individual mitochondria
so the later increase is very consistent
with the vacuole ization of the
mitochondria and the later stage of the
postnatal development which taken
together with the Golgi and ER stress
support the notion of oxidative stress
related mitochondrial damage
so two-dimensional electron microscopy
made the foundation for us to identify
reliable sub cell or domain
primarily affected by the genetic lesion
and decrease in dosage in the large
division in order to fully understand
the extent of seller alterations in the
large division we currently developing
three dimensional analysis pipeline this
is still working progress but I would
like to highlight the value of this
approach the times to complement the
2-dimensional data set and actually to
strengthen these two 2-dimensional data
set we turned into the focused ion beam
which allows us to use the guided source
to mill the sample in a very predictable
way this is shot in the left upper panel
while in a sequence of meaning can
electron image imaging we can produce
zero of electron images representative
on the lower left image represents their
heat texture of the electron gun and
began of my own gun which brought forth
is it fifty to three decrease now the
stout stage is tilted 53 degrees to me
to face the gallon bin the gallon beam
is used to dig trench into the sample
and to prepare a phase of the electron
beam which is shown on the top left
movie here so further as shown here on
the top right movie 10 nanometers the
electron beam sequentially is known as
capturing in which this is a very low
resolution image
that these years actually to find the
fiducial point and to align realigned
image so essentially this is a nano
fabrication multi-step approach which
requires identification of the area of
interest shown on the upper left panel
the left image that position of
protective platinum layers on the four
right image
preparing a trench with fiducial points
a show on the lower left image the final
project that the preparation of the
sample is a trench with a wall facing
the electron beam for imaging a show on
the low right image so the final project
that this approach is a three
dimensional volume in this case the
volume is from the help of also an
inclusive a large delicious Mouse this
volume represents about 630 sections
taken about 10 10 nanometer apart from
each other and the movie illustrates the
ability to decide the volume in
different dimensions
you
ah the important thing here is that this
volume can be segmented we at this point
we use manual segmentation which is
pretty tedious but the after it's or
manual segmentation we can extract
different elements at this volume and we
can create these sub bonus that further
can be isolated that micro bisected and
to look for different changes in mobile
so metric analysis so at the final part
of my talk I would like to highlight the
results of our collaboration with the
Rivest and therefore to add functional
context into electron microscopy
datasets we focus on quantification of
synaptic GABA transmitter
because electrophysiological data
indicated that GABA excitatory
postsynaptic current frequency decreases
in the large deletion for Gavit con
quantification we devised an approach
that can bind spots embedding you know
goal actually we refined it the project
has been very popular and the
transmission electron microscopy and we
adapted this approach for scanning
electron microscopy by using labeling of
the secondary antibody that is
conjugated to ten nanometer gold
particles
gaba concentration and terminals are to
casting the distribution is to casting
when we use very small sample size and
this is my personal experience my
personal painful experience so therefore
we aim to increase the sample size
dramatically but at the same time we
wanted to have resolution supporting
image processing image analysis and
image processing of 10 nanometer golf
particle objects with high reliability
so this slide represents a portion of a
large data set which is acquired in a
similar way as I showed you before the
draft below that the data represents the
intensity along the line so colored
arrows indicate gold particles is the
signal they produce relative to the
uranium counters named the intensity
analysis of the image data allows us to
predict the threshold based segmentation
will result in reliable segmentation and
the majority of the gold part however
small percentage of the gold particles
are shown here with the green arrow
could not be resolved based on tempo
intensity threshold and would require
morphological approaches for separation
more all the segmentation of the
synaptic terminals require manual
segmentation Twitter data words identify
which profile belongs to sentence so
considering this small change challenges
we took a multi-step approach the first
step of this approaching good at placing
the data set in the cloud and segmenting
all the terminals
despite their association with yeah but
calling particles
ah this step was done manually with
multiple investigators involved the
synapse and mitochondria segmentation
was then imported locally where a
multi-step algorithm was developed to
segment the gathered calling dog bark
occurs the algorithm included a stepwise
process of damage sets with global
intensity thresholds followed by open an
open filter and seed based watershed
filters golf particles from the
mitochondria were eliminated finally the
menu segmentation of the synaptic
terminals and algorithmic segmentation
of the golf particles were intersected
the final result is a synaptic outline
which can be associated with different
metrics as in this example gold
particles their area was used to
false-color the gather intensity in each
individual profile of large irritated
from the wild-type gray synapses
indicate synapses displaying below
threshold the other concentrations
whereas the intensity of the profiles
rain ranges from blue to low gaba
concentrations to red for help I GABA
concentration you can note on the left
image that damage is the number of
individual fields that compose the merge
data set after repeating the same
exercise in sample from the large
division and color coding the terminals
the structured image provided immediate
feedback indicating that they are more
frequently blue or low GABA
concentration terminals present in these
samples
here is how our data looks like as the
graph on the Left panel provides an
example of distribution of terminals
based on concentration in both particles
we apply predictive threshold based on
also method to setup a cutoff point for
positive or negative terminals in
general the data supports the notion
that the GABA des is significantly
decreases gabba gabba gabba per terminal
decreases and the area of the gap of
profiles decreases altogether these data
indicate that the gap of pressing up to
compel ability for releases diminish
which may affect in a negative way the
effectiveness effectiveness of the
inhibitory synaptic transmission in the
large division so now at the conclusion
what I want to highlight is that the
high-resolution large area microscopic
data offers powerful support to accept
or reject well tails and positives
mainly because in critic of the power
and the precision of the sample the data
chip through more inclusive imaging has
the ability to increase confidence but
also to open new opportunities not
foreseen in the original experimental
design a large area resolution image
sets have the potential to be expanded
in terms of data structuring which adds
a new dimension to create share data
libraries and collaborations
applying search approach require effort
and this effort is beyond and above
single lab department and even school
centers are important and proud program
programmatic approach is beneficial
always to an instruments capable of
generating such type of data are readily
available they are expensive but if
properly configure it and utilize they
work the investment data management and
mobility is our big challenge at this
point now finally I would like to thank
you first of all I would like to thank
you thank thank like a micro system that
have been very generous to populous over
the past couple of years but here this
this work would never be possible
without the generous support Child
Health and Human Development Institute
at NIH Institute which comes to us in to
form District of Columbia intellectual
and developmental disabilities Research
Center led by vittorio ghoul and the
problem project brand pathology and
development origins and prevention
pediatric nostalgia led by company la
mancha the work is done in the facility
diversity which is George Washington
University and nanofabrication Imaging
Center and this facility supported
generously by the office of
vice-president research a lot of people
played critical role without anything or
anyone of these people this job cannot
be done the team from the nano
fabrication and imaging center with a
shared Cheryl
Chris Chris Brandtner who is our senior
staff scientist here for the electron
microscopy ball upper one teacher given
to join us she has done amazing capaci M
Eagle is our nano fabrication senior
staff scientist she's putting a lot of
effort in preparing samples with the
beam lithography to fork all right
microscopy our part of the crazy
two gates from Arabia played very
instrumental role in providing us with
protocols and analyzing data with the
gold particles also access to the web
view which is cloud-based software for
structuring the data from the School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences in
particular biomedical engineering
chameleon Sheva helps a lot with the
data data analysis and predict
predictive analysis of the gabador
particles
lists and predict or turn the red
student that work for a couple of years
with us and they structure data and did
segmentations terrific job of course
from the neuroscience institute and the
department of anatomy antony la mancha
sally moody leading the program for
pediatric dysphasia that propane ski
David Mandela weeds Sheen one did the
injections and bicycling injections and
Tom Maynard is pretty much very much
responsible for generation of animals
our partners from thermo Fisher can who
has been absolutely vital here for
providing the support and training on
the fifth I see em Tim from the for the
design of the instrumentation for fallen
on theory so for the head pressure
freezing syrup for the work on the
chemical imaging photon counting why
dynamic range imaging and the former
like a Jonathan Boyd who is now in the
Med Emile who could play it's really
vital role here in putting our portfolio
together so I'd like to thank everybody
for joining this webinar and spending
the time and listening to my story thank
you much
Thank You Ana staff for that informative
presentation unfortunately we have run
out of time any questions asked today
and those that are submitted during the
on demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through August 2019 laborat swill alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thanks for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye